PETE LEPAGE: Hi.
I'm Pete, a developer
advocate at Google.
Images play an integral part
of almost every web page
and often account for the most
number of downloaded bytes.
I'm going to show you a
few techniques that you
can use today to serve the
right image to the right device
on your pages without
too much extra work.
First, let's take a look
at background images
served via CSS.
One technique that you
can easily use today
is to combine the
background property
with media queries for
conditional image loading,
based on screen resolution,
viewport size, and more.
On the previous example,
when the browser width
was less than 500
pixels, it only
used the image of the phone.
But when the window was
more than 500 pixels,
the media query kicked in,
adding an image of New York
City to the background.
And instead of showing
the image of a phone,
it showed the image of a tablet.
Media queries can
also apply styles
based on device
pixel ratio, making
it possible to display different
images for 1x and 2x displays.
Chrome, Firefox and Opera
all support the standard min
resolution 2dppx syntax.
Say that 10 times fast.
While Safari and Android browser
both require the older vendor
prefix syntax without
the dppx unit.
Remember, these
styles are only loaded
when the device matches
the media query.
So you always need to
provide a fallback.
This ensures that an
image is always loaded.
Recently Chrome and Safari both
landed the new CSS image-set
function, making it easy to
provide multiple image files.
This allows the browser to
choose the best image depending
on device characteristics,
for example,
a 2x image for a 2x display or
a 1x image for a 1x display.
The syntax is fairly
straightforward--
a comma-separated list
of image declarations
which consists of a
URL string followed
by an image resolution.
Support for the
image-set function
is still new, and
for the time being,
requires the WebKit
vendor prefix.
In addition to loading
the correct image,
the browser will
scale it accordingly.
The browser assumes
that 2x images are twice
as large as 1x images, and will
scale the 2x image so that it
appears the right
size on screen.
Now, for images and markup,
there aren't as many options
yet.
The picture element is
coming, but hasn't landed.
In Safari and Chrome, you can
use the new srcset attribute.
The srcset attribute
enhances the behavior
of the image element, making it
easy to provide multiple image
files for different
device characteristics.
The syntax resource
set is almost identical
to the CSS image-set function,
taking a comma separated list
of image declarations,
which consists
of a URL string followed
by the image resolution.
Because srcset simply adds a new
attribute to the image element,
if a browser doesn't know
how to support srcset,
it simply ignores it and
uses the source attribute.
That also makes it easy
to build a polyfill,
and there are plenty available.
In some cases, images
can be replaced
with CSS or other
browser capabilities.
Rounded corners, gradients,
text shadows, box shadows,
even reflections can
all be done with CSS
without the need to
download an image.
And when someone finally
does ship a 16, or 20, or 30,
or whatever new
display, you won't
need to create another
new image file.
Adding responsive images
to your site is easy.
For background
images, I've shown you
how you can use media
queries or the recently
landed image-set function.
For images and markup,
picture is coming soon.
But today you can use
the srcset attribute.
And there are more
capabilities coming soon.
To learn more about
responsive images,
check out the images section
on the Web Fundamentals site
or just click on
that link on screen.
Yeah.
That one right there.
Perfect.
Thanks for watching.
Go build something awesome.